constant storm to try to figure out what  you're about and you change at 26 you're  all about the hustle you're gonna be a  billionaire or this and that and then  you go to the bar one night and you fall  in love and it changes what you care  about right and then you have a child  and then this happens and then that  happens  things change you just have to always  consistently try to figure out what's  driving you and not because other people  are watching and not because that's what  your dad wants and not that because  that's what you said was gonna happen  and it doesn't look like it your  family's gonna judge you you just have  to be as real with yourself as possible  and that is a very difficult struggle  but when you're not you create enormous  vulnerability and unhappiness